So this is pretty much like the
comedy workshop we do on Zoom
but it's gonna be in person
and we're gonna do
a show in four days.
We must do our exercises.
You're gonna go
through the curtain
and you're gonna
grab this microphone.
I wanna thank you all for
coming to my bar mitzvah.
A man goes to the doctor
and the doctor says,
"You know, you have
to stop masturbating."
He goes, "Why?"
He says, "Because I'm
trying to examine you."
Thank you all for being here.
Has anyone been to a 2pm
comedy show before?
Oh my god!
My wife left me recently.
He's so naughty.
Life is a performance.
Then there was my head surgery.
If my boss ever sees
this, I'm dead.
Laughter is like food
you put in your body.
I would like to be funny but
not in an artificial way.
You know? Genuinely funny.
I think that you
are genuinely funny.
You do?
Yeah.
Really?
Yes.
You're the first person
who's ever told me that.